[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça fait une magnifique fête pour
annoncer à tout le monde
voilà tu vas faire certainement
peut-être une magnifique fête encore
aussi pour la naissance du bébé et a
fait aussi une magnifique tête pour à
9,7 ou non le sexe de son futur bébé
c'est ce qu'on appelle une baby shower
eh bien nous ce soir on va faire ce
qu'on appelle une mamie chômage et pour
qui je suis isabelle m dans une cabine
de douche savez je me suis blessé il ya
cette rageante y aller avec gentil km à
pied battus accompagner les insurgés
attendent derrière ce qu'on discute mais
on peut mettre on reste à côtés
d'isabelle et l'angola où l'avait mal
pour de vrais nobel c'est un enfoncement
thoracique mais non mais non comment le
scénariste inquiète pas j'adore isabelle
vasseur être dans une cabine de douche
je veux dit merde je vais poser il ya un
petit siège en plus un pourri pour l'âme
et noir mat je vais tenter les questions
sur les bébés encore si tu es fin prêt à
devenir papa
ok tu réponds bien tout va bien si tu te
trompes la douche se mettra en route
alors de l'eau coulera sur isabelle
c'est qu'elle déteste ça s'appelle et
ses cheveux là elle a deux formats les
poitrines et l'eau les mamies non non
mais je suis inquiète et ça c'est les
jours de pluie de l'eau de là alors je
n'ai pas les caennais dans tout comme
les douchettes elle son crescendo
ça m'agace ce sera de plus en plus alors
attention première question selon les
pédiatres
quelle est la température maximum pour
le bain d'un nouveau né alors c'est une
voiture maximum pour le bain d'un
nouveau né on le peint d'attirer 30
pas loin de la température du corps je
dirais 30 alors 38 très long
l'audois entre 35 et 38 degrés sexus à
ma bonne réponse de ma mamie mais moi
j'ai 14 ans foncia mais même pas
lorsqu'un bébé pleure il est capable de
faire autant de bruit que un aspirateur
un marteau piqueur ou une scie
circulaire
sachez qu'on a dit à quelqu'un qui a
calculé les décibels un aspirateur
ça s'est amélioré violents comme un bébé
qui pleure il peut atteindre 110
décibels non un aspirateur ne fait que
75 et un marteau piqueur 120 décibels
c'est une si c'est une une petite mamie
show une petite mamie show rien c'est
rien c'est ça de ma mère attention la
question à 5 centimètres près entre sa
naissance son premier anniversaire
de combien de centimètres en moyenne un
bébé grandit t-il à 5 centimètres près
allez à 3 cm et un en vain mot et 25 25
centimes ces 23 cm bonne voie parce que
quand ça rend pas tu te plains les
cancers
on verra
la location
selon l'institut national des études
statistiques durant quelques mois de
l'année observe-t-on le plus de
naissances dans le monde à quel mois de
l'année ouais je dirais bien vu qu'on
fait des souvent des bébés en été je
dirais en mars avril par la marche a
pris alors depuis quelques années le
boom de naissance juin a lieu en
septembre avec apx 23 septembre nouvelle
oui je suis debout alors est ce qu'on
fait bah oui on sait pas ce qu'on fait à
baby shower
or celles qui ne prend qu il que vous
avez choisi pour visée parce que
m
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
sur 100 français combien n'assiste pas à
la naissance de leur paie tout pour tout
caler tout calinous avancé par la mère
des deux enfants seraient nés son mignon
mignon pour tout fou tout cas je dirais
qu'ils n'assistent pas c'est à dire
qu'ils sont bien dans la balle s oui je
ne sont pas dans la pièce évidemment ça
ne va pas bien sont une manne en
carrière on dépose juste prix là je
serai pas dire que je vais aller de
l'autre côté avec l quoi là comme bas
churchill à digérer 20 % 20 % à 25 25 27
25 25 avril at il dit il a dit ben badi
van sant à tomber c'est alors isabelle
ya deux solutions ou vous dites je suis
encore à à 20% à combien de % près
d'ailleurs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
une fois du pis si vous voulez pas faire
hop avec les croissants français combien
n'assiste pas la naissance de leur
enfant
il a dit rapport s'en ressent est ce que
vous me suivez où est la magie 55%
vous êtes sûre et certaine ah non mais
je suis je dit ça mais quand on vous
fait vous préfères tu préfères la tienne
ou la mienne c'est la sienne 55
alors si vous aussi la sienne est plus
proche que la mienne mais la fête ou
pire celle qu'elle peut faire compliqué
de laquelle la mode
alors il est ce que tu es avec moi tu
vas dire la bonne réponse tu avais dit
combien toi moi là 10 20 20 est elle à
10,55 la bonne réponse et si
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]